[Musique]
cette capacité à être crime ce très
rapidement attention petit quizz rapide
depuis combien de temps on n'a pas
tourné une vidéo anecdotes sur sa chaîne
youtube ces terres nos ennemis bravo
quant à patrick bidaud anecdotes depuis
longtemps parce que j'ai tout raconté
sur cette chaîne youtube d'accord ça
fait 10 ans gars et moi je raconte est
tellement de trucs des fois je parle à
des amis je leur raconte un truc et et
maritimes soit attendant je t'arrête
tout de suite à tulle a raconté dans une
vidéo je connais déjà l'histoire je vous
essentiellement raconté dans toutes ses
vidéos anecdotes des trucs qui me sont
arrivées quand j'étais plus jeune quand
j'étais soit ados voire même enfant pour
pas mal d'entre elles aujourd'hui c'est
des trucs que j'ai vécu au cours
quasiment que de la dernière année je
vais pas raconter trois anecdotes
contrairement à d'habitude je veux
raconter deux mais les deux c'est le
même thème c'est des rencontres pas
dante
il m'est arrivé de trucs où j'ai pensé à
vous au moment où ça m'est arrivé je me
suis dit ça y est je vis un [ __ ] de
serait d'horreur c'est mon tour c'est ma
propre histoire je veux bien te raconter
et c'est la vidéo d'aujourd'hui première
anecdote on est en mars 2020 c'est le
premier confinement premier confinement
c'est à dire le confinement que les gens
ont respecté de fou et moi je vous cache
pas prêts dans ce confinement j'avais
deux petits plaisirs le premier c'était
de live beaucoup plus qu'habituellement
ce qui avait plein de gens qui étaient
devant l'ordi et c'était il y avait une
belle ambiance sur internet en vrai
beaucoup plus que dans la vraie vie nous
sommes en guerre et j'avais un deuxième
titre que plein de gens ont eu ici c'est
sur ce qu'avait des chiens c'était
sortir natsu pourquoi c'était beaucoup
plus qui font que d'habitude parce que
je pouvais marcher au milieu de la route
j'en avais rien à [ __ ] paris c'était
devenu ma ville mais que j'avais
l'impression d'être le shérif d une
ambiance trop bizarre et hyper agréable
pour tous ceux qui avaient un chien
parce qu'en gros on était les seuls à
avoir le droit de sortir et jamais
j'aurais imaginé marché dans paris
désert bref on est jeudi soir le jus
d'histoire vous savez si vous êtes un
secours willows de qualité qui enlève
switch au petit autopromo la vie de fait
ce soir là je sais pas pourquoi mais le
live il finit tard et fini autour de 3
heures du matin comme tous les soirs et
comme à chaque fois que je finis de live
je prends là dessus et je le sors mais
ce soir là je vais me taper un kiff je
me dis [ __ ] paris est vide je veux
voir les champs elysées vide et marcher
au milieu de la route petit kiff bizarre
inédit où je pourrai plus jamais faire
j'arrive sur place chez au milieu de la
grande avenue
pas un bruit autour de moi pas une
voiture par une personne juste moi natsu
et l'arc de triomphe mais petit gars
quand même ce soir là c'est le soir où
il ya eu une méga tempête à paris je
passe vous souvenez il y avait un vent
de malades
il pleuvait à torrent ch au milieu de
cette pluie battante c'est beau ça fait
des reflets par terre c'est un peu les
moments où tu es d'une expo dans tes
oreilles je vais les étoiles vagabonde
tu marches elle étudie pas
tran ba de là vous voyez pas bref je
marchais en train de remonter l'avenue
des champs elysées et que vous jouez au
loin un homme qui court très vite et qui
court très vite vers moi au début je
m'inquiète pas plus que ça et puis je me
dis à ta ta ta ta n'ya personne dehors à
part moi c'est forcément vers - qui
courent et ils se rapprochent ils se
rapprochent et se rapproche et qu'est ce
que je fais moi comme une énorme victime
écoutez moi bien je fais un petit angle
droit pour retourner sur le trottoir en
mode genre pile à ce moment là comme par
hasard j'ai tu t'en veux c'est de
marcher sur le trottoir
et puis j'entends les bruits de pas qui
s'accentue qui s'accentue et je
comprends que tu tiens comme par hasard
le gars aussi décidé de prendre la
direction du trottoir c'est étrange ça
et là il se passe ce qui devait arriver
le mec vous fait quand ça m'arrive ce
genre de truc je nie je suis dans le
déni le plus total le déni s'est regardé
n'a souffert a les notes sous tu marches
du coup je m'éloigne avec une téléphone
dans la main et le gars continuent de me
parler fait et il devient un peu
agressif je me dis bon le gâter une
grosse victime qui fuit tout conflit ou
toute situation présente mais là let's
go t'as pas le choix il va falloir gérer
ce truc je me retourne j'affronte ma
destinée je prends les choses en main je
le vois il est méga propre sur lui mais
il a l'air explosé je sais pas s'il est
bourré de malade s'il a pris de la
drogue j'en sais rien mais il a l'air
éclaté il s'approche de moi et tend la
main pour prendre mon téléphone
c'est pas une manière de frère
j'étais à deux doigts de lui donner
évidemment je range de téléphone dans ma
poche et judy frérot désolé non vers la
fnac et là il me regarde et y dîne
phrase en arabe
moi je vous cache pas les mots arabes
que je connais ses stars foulard
inch'allah mais je vais quand même me
répondre donc je me mets à lui parler
anglais avec l'accent le même que j'ai
dans les vidéos sourire hide and seek
arabique have good evening news this 180
degrés ça dégage
et là il dit un mot qui résonne au moins
je me fais je me dis mais le mec est là
en détresse pocket qu'il a besoin de mon
téléphone et là je sors mon téléphone et
j'ouvre google traduction
il se met à parler arabe dans mon
téléphone est là la traduction sa fiche
je suis de dubaï je devais prendre un
train à gare de l'est mais on m'a tout
volé ça fait trois heures que je marche
dans paris
s'il te plaît aide moi moi moi l'écho
sur le moi j'ai vraiment eu dans ma tête
en lisant le truc et là je le regarde et
je comprends qu'en fait il est ni bourré
lee drogué il est juste en état de choc
absolu ce qui fait à peu près les mêmes
effets que si tu prends du lsd de
l'alcool et de la weed en même temps et
là ils marchent montel des mains je me
dis en tout ça n'était qu'une mascarade
et c'est donc bel et bien un voleur et
quelques secondes plus tard il me remet
mon téléphone est en fait il venait
d'ajouter quelqu'un dans mes contacts et
de lancer une convoite ça va avec lui et
donc je comprends que ces numéros d'un
de ses proches et qu'il faut que je la
elle pour que ce mec ne vienne en aide
quelques secondes plus tard je suis en
face time avec un mec à dubaï en haut
d'une tour 0 blague
il me dit me donne pas tort de free road
quand même en train d'aider ton frère
qui en slip dans paris à 3 heures du mat
tu peux juste être un peu policé du coup
je filme ont-elles à son voisin les deux
ils parlent dix minutes 10 minutes je
sais pas ce qui se raconte mais ils
commencent à me péter les couilles j'ai
envie de rentrer chez moi j'ai envie de
dormir dix minutes plus tard je récupère
mon tel le frère du mec est toujours en
facetime et me dit écoute à q-park bon
son action était différent mais il était
à chier comme le meilleur voilà je me
permets je suis baiser je dois attendre
avec lui le temps que son frère rappel
puisque son seul point de contact c'est
mon téléphone à moi c'est horrible je
suis bloqué mais d'un autre côté je me
dis bon le gars a compris que je venais
en aide à son frère il va faire vite le
frérot dans sa tour à dubaï va bombarder
elle avait à peine la chambre d'hôtel
dans trois minutes à les bouquets 40
minutes quarante minutes à essayer de
créer de la complicité avec un mec qui
ne parle pas ma langue
heureusement il y avait là dessous c'est
à dire ont caressé chacun notre tour
natsu et c'est comme ça qu'on crée un
lien entre nous pendant ces 40 minutes
évidemment j'en vois plein de messages
au frère du maire eliane les deux petits
trucs là de boîtes qui montrent que le
gars voient mes messages mais que juste
humiliés or et pendant ce temps où
j'attends désespérément une réponse du
frère du mec et surtout une adresse pour
que le foot dans un hummer et qu'il
aille à son hôtel et que je jure courses
que j'avais dans ma vie un nouveau
personnage fait son apparition une meuf
habillé tout en blanc arrive vers nous
évidemment je pense à d'un blanc je suis
pas bien je me dis ok je vais c'est une
malédiction lâché en train de faire
marabouté par des inconnus je suis foutu
cette meuf est donc pieds nus en robe
blanche et en relevant un peu les yeux
jusqu'à son visage je vois qu'elle a des
cheveux très longs noirs qui lui cache
un peu le visage donc ça me fait penser
à the grudge et the ring je suis pas
très à l'aise et surtout elle pisse le
sang de la bouche d'accord là je me fais
un film dans ma tête je me dis ok c'est
un cartel le mec de dubaï c'est le chef
en fait quand ils parlaient arabe il
leur demander l'adresse précise où on
est et leur a ordonné de me maintenir à
cet endroit précis le temps qu'ils
envoient un véhicule pour me kidnapper
je vous jure que je me dis ça je suis
pas bien je me disais je regarde là
dessous en espérant qu'ils défendent et
nice où il se fait passer le crâne par
le mec de dubaï
alors je voudrais qu'il le monde
d'accord et quand la meuf arrive à notre
niveau elle tend sa main et elle dit une
clope et quand même des clopes et du son
en belgique et là je vous cache pas
c'est la première fois de ma vie où j'ai
regretté de foot pas fumer je me suis
dit [ __ ] si je donne pas sa clope
elle me plante et après quatre secondes
de blanc ressenti 4000 ans dans un geste
héroïque
dubaï ils sortent une cigarette cette
charmante dame arrache la clope de la
voie du mec littéralement et elle repart
tout doucement vers l'horizon
je ne sais toujours pas qui est cette
dame je sais pas ce qui lui arrive et
gérer les deux c'était trop dur les gars
j'ai pas mon bafa bref j'ai à peine le
temps de réaliser ce qui vient de se
passer
je reçois un appel vidéo évidemment qui
est au bout du fil le frère du gars
toujours dans sa tour à dubaï et je
décroche il dit un truc très rapide il
dit attends je comprends pas bien là ça
fait une heure je m'occupe de son frêle
en plus de ça le mec crois que je vais
appeler un email je les fais tout de
suite à hubert védrine en plus de ça je
mets l'adresse de l'hôtel dans le hub r
je dis aux frères c'est bon et là j'ai
quand même eu un mais merde fait -
virement encore comme c'est le
confinement le ebay rimer genre milan
arrivé à ce moment là et les genres 4h50
du match je n'en peux plus la voiture
arrive elle s'arrête devant nous la
vitre du conducteur s'ouvre et le mec
dit il est bourré ton pote là je le
prends pas moi il va germer dans ma
caisse
[Musique]
et là j'ai été très honnête avec ce
chauffeur là le squeeze gentil victimes
il s'est volatilisé je regarde le
chauffeur judy écoute moi bien ce mec là
il vient de dubaï
il a plus de téléphone plus d'argent
plus rien je viens de passer deux heures
avec son frère hôtel qui était en haut
d'une tour dans l'opulence je t'ai
appelé pour conduire ce mec dans son
hôtel à mes frais et toi tu ouvres la
vitre étudie et maury tombera il ne
prend pas et du lieu c'est la rare fois
ma vie où j'ai de l'autorité sur qui que
ce soit regardez dit ok fait le monter
et là moi c'est générique de fin
[Musique]
aude fin du générique je réalise que
mike powell m'a même pas dit merci ou
quoi que ce soit il est juste monter
dans la voiture ans en battant les
couilles de moi et c'est à ce moment je
me suis dit [ __ ] j'suis vraiment une
grosse victime
pourquoi je vous ai raconté cette
anecdote parce que c'est la seule fois
où déjà j'ai croisé la dame blanche et
où des mecs de dubaï ont fait de moi
leurs esclaves en une minute 20 et j'ai
presque aimé ça bref nouvelle anecdote
celle ci c'est la rencontre la plus
flippante de ma vie carrément j'ai
hésité à la raconter tellement c'est un
truc que j'ai très très très mal vécu
vraiment c'était à cinq mois avec le
chiot l'on venait de partir deux
semaines chez un pote part en france
vient le moment du retour et le vol
retour c'est un vol relou à 6h du mat
c'est les vols relou parce que la veille
c'est le dernier soir donc forcément tu
va traîner jusqu'à très tard et tu dis
je danse je dors pas bref nous on a fait
le choix de dormir un cycle donc une
heure et demie de sommeil on se lève on
est en ramasse il fait nuit je suis pas
bien on dit au revoir à notre pote est
tout on se casse on arrive à l'aéroport
tout se passe bien guichetiers passeport
sécurité un peu la flemme de retirer la
ceinture c'est pas grave on le fait
qu'ils café à elle est dégueulasse mais
quand même et j'en ai besoin mais les
dégueulasse direction la porte
d'embarquement et là je me fais pas mal
reconnaître que c'est un vol dans lequel
il est pas mal de français bon bref des
gens sympas c'est toujours marrant de se
croiser à 6h du mat explosé par la
fatigue dans un aéroport dans un autre
pays c'est des moments qu'on aime c'est
drôle bref
enfin on est appelé pour monter dans
l'avion enfin j'ai pu voir à m'asseoir
et dormir deux heures dans la position
la moins confortable il sort l'humanité
on rentre enfin dans l'avion avec
lorraine on arrive à notre ange et la
19e ya un mec est assis côté extérieur
de m'arranger et donc on doit passer
devant lui ce moment un peu gênante je
connais pour atteindre nos places et ce
mec c'est le seul gars de tout l'avion
qui n'a pas masquer mais c'est rien à
côté de ce qui suit j'arrive au niveau
du mec au moment j'ouvre la bouche pour
lui dire de se lever il me regarde dans
les yeux et il me dit squeeze tu le sais
pas encore mais tu es un homme mort rien
quand je vous redis cette phrase je suis
pas bien les gars y'a pas de rire sur
son visage
et même s'il y avait un rire c'est juste
pas drôle comme phrase et là j'ai pas le
temps de comprendre ce qui va m'arriver
qu'il se lève et ils se poussent pour
que j'aille m'asseoir à côté de lui je
vais passer deux heures assis à côté
d'un mec m'a regardé froidement me
disant squeeze tu le sais pas encore
mais d'un homme mort on les attend les
journées comme ça à let's go sur l'aim
dit il a dit ce que j'ai entendu là et
là un retour de squeeze la victime oui
mais c'est une blague et tous âges route
ambiance ventes d'avions cela fait des
blagues il est tout à l heure du matin
et je regarde le mec lui il est comme ça
lorraine elle s'assoit au fond côté
hublot moi je m'assois au milieu oui lui
ça soit côté ranger on est tous les
trois côte à côte il a toujours pas dit
un mot de plus depuis cette phrase
d'accord juste cette phrase est là je
deviens complètement méfiant parano j'ai
vraiment un très mauvais feeling et je
me dit une phrase il va faire exploser
l'avion
c'est pour ça qu'il a dit que j'étais un
homme mort et que je savais pas encore
il va faire exploser l'avion et lorraine
elle qui est la personne la plus de
schille du monde elle et l'a posée elle
sort une feuille commence à dessiner
elle en a rien à [ __ ] dites-vous
j'étais tellement panique c'est pas une
blague j'ai fait un truc horrible pour
un proche mais j'ai envoyé un message à
un proche dans lequel je le dis il ya un
mec qui vient de me dire je suis un
homme mort je ne sais pas encore sa
tenue c'est ça y ressemble à ça il a tel
âge si jamais quelque chose m'arrive bah
voilà c'était lui le pire message à
recevant c'est celui là et donc du coin
de l'oeil je me mets à le regarder et là
ce que je vois ça me plaît pas du tout
le gars il est assis comme ça il a le
signe du stress du pied qui fait ça ils
se touchent un peu les maïs gratte la
jambe comme ça jette des coups d'oeil
dans le couloir comme ça ensuite il
regarde l'heure ensuite il regarde son
sac et il fait ça encore et encore j'ai
trop peur de découvrir ce qui a dans son
sac et j'ai trop peur qu'ils fassent
vraiment qu'ils me tuent quoi [ __ ]
c'est pas normal de dire une phrase
comme ça dans un avion un mec que tu
connais pas c'est pas normal
l'avion décolle et une fois qu'on est en
l'air il baisse vers son sac et il le
désire
il sort un truc de son sac un bouquin de
philo et là je me dis mais attend en
fait je suis trop sur la défensive
détends-toi l'uqat et dormi qu'une heure
et demie cette monte à la tête là en
fait tu le sais pas encore mais tu es un
homme mort ces genres une phrase
philosophique qu'alain sens profond mais
ça m'échappe parce que moi je suis pas
très bon en philo et là il sort son
téléphone
et là je vois le fond d'écran de son
téléphone je les reproduis pour vous
c'est ça ça c'est son fond d'écran de
tous les fonds d'écran qui existent lui
l'ami celui là et là gros soulagement
il commence à me parle je vais pouvoir
creuse essayer de comprendre qui est ce
m qu'est-ce qu'il veut pourquoi il a un
oeil de merde en fond d'écran mais je
vous parle j'ai pas osé lui demander
pourquoi il m'avait dit cette phrase
j'ai préféré croire que ce moment
n'était jamais arrivé n'existait pas et
c'est là que j'ai eu la discussion la
plus celle où de toute ma [ __ ] de vie
selon lui il était en croisière depuis
deux semaines et donc les croisières le
bateau s'arrête dans plusieurs villes
etc
les gens descendent il faut une activité
plutôt monde remonte sur bateau un jour
l'activité s'était casino lui il est
sorti du casino pour aller retirer de
l'argent
sauf qu'il a un peu tardé et quand il
est revenu au bâton lui a dit
vous êtes sorti du groupe vous pouvais
plus monter dans le bateau et le bateau
est parti sans lui et s'est retrouvé
baiser et c'est pour ça qu'il était dans
ce vol évidemment dans pendant qu'on
discute il parle et mes réponses c'est
essentiellement des ah mais non
ouais grave grave et puis d'un coup il
rend dans des sujets un peu plus dit est
dit une phrase qui me fait un peu mal il
dit non mais tu es quelqu'un si c'est
pour une bonne raison
c'est pas grave évidemment je suis
révoltée par ce qu'il vient de dire et
je veux lui faire comprendre que non tu
es c'est pas ok si tu as une bonne
raison ou pas du tout donc je me tourne
vers lui je lui dis ah ouais c'est vrai
le retour de ce quiz et la victime let's
go et la lega il me raconte des trucs
dingues me dit par exemple il est allé
voir une escorte sauf que je cite il n'a
pas réussi à bander à cause du
préservatif et ça traumatise et ses
couilles c'est ce qu'il a dit mot pour
mot et là ils me regardent d'un air très
sérieux je m'apprête à ce qu'ils me
disent tu as bien compris que tu étais
un homme mort il ne le savait pas encore
mais à la place il dit il faut que je
rappelle un micro y qui elles sont
vraiment waouh hockey mike basirat
rappelle le leur il ya aucun problème
mais fait juste papeete l'avion n'y a
pas de soucis vas-y mon frérot les gars
ces discussions sur ses couilles elle a
duré trois minutes
le vol a duré deux heures 50 avez vous
une idée du nombre de choses que j'ai pu
entendre pendant ce vol petit best-of
qualitativement toutes les quantités
sont pareil quand c'est l'automne tu as
une sensation qui s'appelle l'automne là
on est au niveau 1 de la réflexion le
but c'est d'être immortel
ça n'existe pas les dinosaures or quand
je dis boss j'utilise un mot anglais
c'est la honte tout ce qui est important
est contrôlable
je me souviens de ma naissance la
médecine est inutile je n'ai plus
d'émotions si j'arrive à débloquer
toutes mes capacités je n'irai plus
jamais dans un aéroport
messieurs nous commençons notre descente
vers paris charles de gaulle oui mais
pendant tout le vol les gars j'ai écouté
j'ai répondu j'ai participé aux débats
de vie et de société de ce gars juste
parce que j'avais peur qu'ils fassent
exploser l'avion serait bon bref
surprise je suis là l'avion n'a pas
explosé ou en fait le mec était
parfaitement inoffensif mais juste il
était trop bizarre et surtout je serai
jamais pourquoi quand je suis arrivé à
côté de lui et m'a regardé dans les yeux
et m'a dit squeeze tu le sais pas encore
mais d'un homme mort avec l'air le plus
sérieux qui soit le même air que quand
un mec de mandat une meuf de l'épousé
quoi c'est un moment sérieux de fou quoi
c'est horrible bref à toi cher inconnu
de l'avion j'espère que nos chemins ne
se croiseront plus jamais eh bien
écoutez j'espère cette vidéo anecdote
vous a plu ça faisait un an et demi
qu'on n'en avait pas fait je sais pas si
j'ai envie de me souhaiter de revivre
des trucs chelous pour pouvoir en faire
une vidéo non je préfère l'europe à
revivre ces trucs là on fera les gros
sur une chose mais surtout celle de
l'avion là ça m'a vraiment les gars je
vous jure
j'étais pas bien quoi ça a vraiment eu
un impact sur moi enfin j'espère que ça
vous a plu j'espère que j'ai bien
raconter ça on se retouve attendant une
prochaine vidéo je vous souhaite de ne
pas avoir de rencontre étrange passé une
très bonne journée soirée matinée nuit
peu importe il était aux essieux
[Musique]